emilio doménech is the spanish correspondent
in the usa for the spanish chain lasexta
we will talk about the election today
surveys hispanic voters and much more
welcome emilio doménech well emilio
to begin with a bit like a
journalist from spain i can't even
imagine how you see this election
so  Strange, crazy in practice in the US
Give
us a general perspective of a
Spanish journalist observing what
is happening here It is curious because at
the moment I am very twittery
Today you spent a lot of time on Twitter in
Spain Those who are most active on
Twitter tend to be  those who are pro
trump I don't know if you know there is a party in
Spain called box which is a
party more
to the right I am very
conservative and so when you tweet
things about trump especially now that
they are talking about so many polls
because cheating for  On top of that there is a part
of the electorate in Spain' that is very
active on Twitter that is very
critical of all kinds  of polls that may
be ahead and the whole issue of hunter that
has been seen these weeks the same then
the perception is a little different from
what perhaps can be expected
by the Americans who sometimes
say is that from the outside you must think
that  we are crazy no but it is used yes it
is true that at the political level
many of the things that
are done here in the usa are being copied in spain
so we no longer see it as something
so foreign but even so it continues to
surprise some of the
decisions that trump makes and above all the message
no and the pse is such a reactionary message and
that I think is what
continues to surprise the most from such a
relevant political figure in
the US voters of Hispanic origin whether from
Central America or South America
are generally  Democratic voters The most
notable exception would be Cuban-Americans who lean
toward an anti-Castro thing are
more likely to vote Republican than the
population of Spain than  e lives in the usa
as it is centered on the political spectrum
i would say that they lean much more towards the
democrats because after all
those who come to the united states and are
spanish come because they have had
pretty good job opportunities
and therefore that always tends to be  He tends to
throw people who have more money,
so it seems to me that the same
trend that we have seen here in the US
with the whole issue of the white professional class,
the suv bours that have ended up
opting for the Democrats, at least
in the Trump era, it seems to me.
That bubble is a bit similar. In the
end, the Spanish bubble is the same
urban bubble as the cities, so
you will always see the largest Spanish communities in New York, in
Miami, especially in Florida, and there it
seems to me that the trend is going to  always be
more democrat staying a few
days until the election although the truth
is that this year the election is already
happening more than 72 million  votes
already with good not all counted but
some already counted I want to think a
little about the impact that the Hispanic voter can have
in particular states of particular importance
in this election what are
those states and as you see a bit of the
environment
it seems to me that the states  the four most
decisive at the level of
Latino voters are Florida that you mentioned
before the community of Cuban Americans
which is a very important community
especially in Miami Dade County
I think that there we can be a little
pending on November 3 how is the
participation according to according to that
county and especially how are the
trends for trampó para bailén then
you have texas the state of texas that this
year it seems that it is more hinge than
ever it is not more cough as they would call it in the
usa than ever and then you have now and
zone and nevada what nevada we already know that it
is a state that during the
democratic primaries voted for bernie sanders no
longer embraced that fig  ure populist and
yet now we see that the differences
that bailén has with respect to trump
among those Latino voters are not as
great as those that hillary
clinton had in 2016 so that has been one
of the problems that democrats have tried
to tackle throughout  over the
last few months and it doesn't seem to have
worked entirely well but it does
seem that those were the four states
where Hispanics are going to be the most determinant
and I would say one more that we
have to be attentive if in the end
we see
what  trump is marking the differences very well
in states like pennsylvania
because in pennsylvania there is a part on
the outskirts of philadelphia which is where
the area of ​​the city of allentown
lancaster is also called the 222
latino corridor which is an area where the
community  Hispanic has emerged a lot
in recent years and where that voter that
we always know has lower
turnout even so if the
differences end  n being a few
thousand votes as in 2016, it can
be key if there are a few
electoral situations where Pennsylvania would remain
as the state that decides
which of the two candidates reaches 270
electoral votes and also Pennsylvania
from the states that do not count votes until
the closing of the occasion on Tuesday itself
is the only state that could determine
the winner of those that do not count until the
last moment, so it could be the
most important state this year
totally in fact the other two that do
not start counting until the day
of  the elections or the day before it
seems to me that my girl starts counting
the day before but they are those states
we have already seen through the polls it has appeared
in some of the abc washington post' plus 17
points joe biden in wisconsin so
pennsylvania is what  what do you say that
most scenarios is the
decisive state and it seems to me that for that
reason clearly the candidates are
spending so much time there I see  It
is true that he is close to his home
in Wilmington, Delaware, but he has been
like ten times compared to the
next state, Florida, which has spent
three, because this year we do not see
as significant support for the
Democratic candidate as what we  We saw
in 2016, for example, it is due to a
particular Hispanic subpopulation, for
example, Cubans and others. There is another
explanation as to how this happened
because the black population that
frequently votes 90 and between 89 and
22 for the Democratic candidate continues to
support the country.  More or less 92% of the
Hispanic population is different because it
is very difficult because the issue with the
polls and the public opinion of
Latinos, being such a
complex community that has such different origins,
not because in the end you have the
part of Central America, you have Mexico.  that
they are immigrants who
over the last few generations have
settled more in what is the
border with Mexico but then
However, you have Cuban Americans, you also have
Venezuelans
or Puerto Ricans who have gone to
a state like Florida or even
Pennsylvania, as I mentioned before,
so the pollsters sometimes
have a lot of trouble getting an
idea of ​​what the opinion of that part
of the electorate is because sometimes the  They
treat African-Americans as monolithic voters, and sometimes there is a
lot of criticism of this. You say, it's not that
it's a monolithic voter, but we
have to take into account that more
than 90% vote for Democrats, so
in that aspect, yes, there is a  a
clear difference that byd was criticized once
for saying something similar because it was not
explained well but there was a
super interesting article in texas mount lee
this week that talked about
latino voters in texas and said that the
issue is
very complex because sometimes  Sometimes
Latinos feel they are very independent voters,
they are not loyal at all when it comes to
parties, that is, they do not know  they adapt
throughout the families the issue is that they
do not vote the participation of Latinos
is not very high and this has been coming
for several generations
so if you in your family do not have
a tradition of going to vote in
the end that tradition dies out  and
that is why participation is so low, but
that does not mean that Hispanics
are not involved in politics, they
simply sometimes feel that they
are outside the system and that
politicians do not go to those communities and
they do not feel represented because in
the end there is a  very large disconnection
that prevents their voters from not only getting
involved at the party level but
then in the end there is that loyalty that does
exist, for example, with
African-Americans and I think that is one
of the reasons why now
perhaps they trust more a  little trapped in
that honest figure in quotes and
also that at an economic level it
has the highest popularity
ratings because in any other parameter  etro
management of coronavirus management of
racial tensions is going to get
much better grades but it
always gets good grades and it
also happens with Hispanics so I think that a
population so concerned about unemployment that in
the end they have been greatly affected in
states like  Nevada, where they have the
highest unemployment rates in the entire
country, I think that this is also an
important rate to take into account for
voters who, as I was saying,
feel a little more independent. My
last question, the president said
many times that it is possible.  that we do not
know who the winner of the
election is for days weeks and he even said
months that I do not believe for a moment
but when you think that
the winner
is going to be known, it seems to me that they are going to know and I am going to tell you this
to say for the first time in public
because I haven't said it yet but it
seems to me that it will be known relatively
soon because Arizona in
North Carolina and especially Florida are going to count
votes very quickly.  do then it is probable
that before midnight we already have
an approximate idea of ​​what is happening
in the north highway and in florida and if
any of those states win them I
baiden it seems to me that the night is over
and now in these moments I leave  a
narrow favorite, well, margin by
very small margins, but the trend
is what it is and the experts that
I trust waserman nate with nate
silver also from fall city gate I think
they all point to the same idea which is
that it will  to be on track to win these
elections, so it wouldn't surprise
me if we got a
relatively early result and then
we just wait to
see what happens at the rush bell with
Pennsylvania and so on and in Arizona or
Texas for example, what's going to happen?  to be like the
big news of the week wow so
let's go we're going to have to revisit this
interview on Wednesday to see
so that you can quarrel with me it's clear exactly
not but I've been around for a long time
Saying that it does not seem to me that it
will be a whole week, I think that
at most we are talking about
three or four days and that is only if it
ends up depending on, for example,
Pennsylvania or one or two states and it is very
possible that at midnight in  the
east coast we already know i think i
am and pennsylvania is the only thing that
scares me that if in the end it ends up being the
decisive state if there can be
disputes regarding voting by mail
absolutely these do not count and so on and
those disputes can end up in the hands
from the supreme court
now with amy con and berger which is a totally different
story
that we will leave for another day
emilio thank you very much for your
time
thanks to you good luck see you later